[Music]
the Victoria Day long weekend is usually
the unofficial start of summer but
something feels a bit glum this year
summer vacation plans are either
cancelled or in limbo unless you are
planning to stick close to home because
that's where most of us will be a nip
sauce poll conducted exclusively for
global news found even if they were
allowed only 20% of Canadians surveyed
said they'd likely travel outside the
country in 2020 50 percent said they
likely wouldn't slightly more people are
open to domestic travel 37% said they'd
venture beyond their home province
Travel is at a standstill few industries
have fallen as far as fast and when it
does recover things will look a lot
different
Jackson prosecco explains over the years
Canadians Bob and Dorothy Grubb have
taken more than a dozen cruisers their
last trip sailed right into a global
health crisis in March they were onboard
the Grand Princess trapped off the coast
of California as a mysterious virus
spread through the passengers and crew
they first noticed something wasn't
right when their favorite waiter wasn't
at dinner one evening he just wasn't
there and asked what happened oh he's
off sick ok so the next day he is back
and I said Oh exam you're good to see
you back I said but you look tired said
I'm ok the next day Xavier isn't there
he's lost sick again soon the US Coast
Guard was airlifting kovat 19 test kits
to the boat the grubs were confined to
their cabin waiting for a plan to get
off the ship and get home to British
Columbia without getting sick after our
cabins meals placed at our door with a
knock on the door and that was the end
of any contact with people those were
the first days of the pandemic before
every cruise ship stopped sailing before
air travel dropped of staggering 95%
before the Las Vegas Strip
empty it's safe to say travelers and the
travel industry have never seen anything
like this
so my last flight was on March 1st and I
can't remember a time I've gone this
long without being in the sky Brian
Kelly is better known as the points guy
as founder of the travel website he
warns this shock to the system will lead
to immediate and permanent changes to
the way we travel should you expect that
when you check into a hotel or get on a
plane that someone's going to be taking
your temperature health checks are here
to stay just like after 9/11 lengthy
airport checks were implemented the same
will be happening and is happening in
the airline space right now Emirates is
actually doing instant ko bid tests and
Etihad has temperature checks on their
check-in kiosks and those are just a
couple of the ways that the travel
experience will be changed forever
Air Canada will be the first airline in
North America to do temperature checks
on every passenger not just to stop
travelers from infecting each other but
because the public is nervous very
nervous about getting back out there I
hope they don't think that things are
going to be exactly as they were prior
to Kovan 19 Laurie Pennington gray is a
professor in the department of tourism
at the University of Florida the school
publishes a travel anxiety index it
shows fear and worry about travel have
increased a whopping 311 percent from
pre coronavirus days do people even want
to travel right now the majority of the
research is saying that they're still
you know some pent up demand but that
they're gonna wait six months or so
before they start to think about their
travel and a lot of that has to do with
this understanding of what the industry
is going to do to keep them safe
long before kovat 19 supermodel Naomi
Campbell documented her own airplane
disinfection routine back then it seemed
over-the-top I do not care
nobody's laughing now at American
Airlines caring for you is our priority
airlines have come to realize that deep
cleaning is a must so are masks for
flight attendants and passengers a
company called germ Falcon is developing
equipment to disinfect the entire cabin
between flights using ultraviolet light
major hotel chains are partnering with
name-brand disinfectant manufacturers
expect big changes when cruise ships
finally do return to the sea and so the
research also suggests that more than
60% expects that the industry is going
to have to provide you know PPE for the
visitors at touch points throughout the
travel experience and that there's more
than 70% that say that there's an
expectation that they're going to share
what they're doing with the visitor as
far as keeping that visitor safe there's
one basic problem the industry can't
overcome social distancing it's hard to
do in a hotel lobby or on board a cruise
ship and virtually impossible on a plane
train or bus that hasn't stopped the
rush to return to the high seas Carnival
Cruises aims to sail again in August
they've seen a remarkable surgeon
bookings for those first few trips
mostly from young people who in fact are
eager to travel of course the pandemic
may change those plans there's still a
chance those first sailings could be
called off I think the biggest
calculation is going to have to be how
many people am I going to to be around
and expose myself to and be exposed by
them in in in in various settings and
and what are the current recommendations
and and why
I one of my comfortable whiz some
airlines have tried to space out
passengers by leaving middle seats open
but they can't do that forever empty
seats don't make money and the airlines
are in dire straits Delta is losing 60
million dollars a day
Air Canada lost more than 1 billion
dollars in the first quarter carriers
are sending hundreds of older planes to
the scrapyard anticipating demand will
take years to return to what it was
most have said they'll emerge smaller
some likely won't survive even with
government bailouts
unfortunately the industry will
consolidate the weak airlines especially
budget airlines will not have the funds
to compete with the majors so the
airline industry has never seen a
challenge like this and they've got a
long road to recovery since business
travel and leisure travel are both off a
cliff those problems are cascading
through an industry that's responsible
for one in 10 jobs worldwide it is
across the board because their
connectivity and the dependency for all
these industries within this sector is
significant what we call the domino
effect in in this case like if one
airline is being impacted then you have
of course a travel agency the tour
operators their hotels no one is
expecting a quick rebound in the short
term there aren't many places to travel
to not with borders closed and not with
many countries implementing mandatory
quarantine on arrival nobody is going to
spend two weeks vacation enforced
isolation
longer-term businesses may decide travel
is just not worth the risk and when it
comes time to relax more of us may opt
to stick close to home 2020 may be the
year of the road trip back in BC the
Grubbs future vacation plans definitely
look different no flights and no cruises
not now and probably not anytime soon
unless we can see a vaccine that's going
to work
cleaning the stepped-up on the ships
we wouldn't be touring which is not
willing to take that risk we wouldn't be
going we've made the decision we're not
going on a cruise period that's end the
story too risky to ski
[Music]